we the people of the united states 130
million of us a great free dynamic nation
north south east and west more than three million
sprawling miles between the restless oceans this
is our land and here we thrive the most advanced
most amazing people on the face of the globe
melting pot of all the peoples of the
earth molded into that remarkable race
americans heads high heads low chins up and
down banker and laborer housewife and parlormaid
all kinds and colors of people most of us
too preoccupied to step aside and watch
ourselves on parade but here we are you and
i representing the greatest nation on earth
but we're always human and
often funny we the funny people
130 million alice's in a fabulous wonderland
that we ourselves have created we build such
tall buildings that they seem to scrape the sky at
first we look up at them in amazement after that
most of us hurry along without ever looking
up or pondering the wonder of a great city
one day we're playing in some back lot and then
the next day 60 000 people pay to watch us play
expert observers broadcast our games to
all the world and when the crowd cheers
through our loudspeakers we can
hear today's history in the making
the roar of crowds or guns are we impressed
a little humble before such wonders in
communication
oh turn it off there's nothing on the radio
anymore we the amazing people living in a world
of our own making a world of delightful contrasts
and contradictions now good people there is one
thought i wish to leave with you bro coy french
beers hey baby get your evening party here
happy birthday to yous happy birthday to yous
please send me some money happy birthdays to
you we the funny people one day we bet the
shirt off our backs that something can't be done
and the next day we're taking it for granted
what kind of a world have we made for ourselves
our civilization moves on wheels between the two
oceans we can roll ourselves and our goods with
a speed and certainty and diminishing cost that
would have astonished our grandparents and our
parents big trucks for big goods door-to-door
across the continent streamlined bullets of
personal transportation 25 million of them cars
for work and cars for play highways for adventure
for the transportation of petticoats and pig iron
highways for fresh vegetables and honeymooners
everybody rides everybody's life is
richer and fuller in the world on wheels
enough cars to carry all of us at one time
all of us amazing funny people men women and
children old and young fat and thin banker
laborer doctor farmer merchant and housewife
some of us lazing along blocking traffic some of
us in a hurry scooting in and out taking chances
and acting silly sometimes we're careful and
patient and friendly sometimes we're careless or
worse it takes all of us to make up america we're
the people you and me the wonderful funny people
on wheels we laugh when our mobile civilization
is called a miracle it's too commonplace we're
used to this wonderful age of horsepower it
seems as if it's always been this way but
there was a time not so long ago when wheels turn
more slowly they look pretty funny to us now but
we used to dress like that and we used to think
this was big romantic stuff the bicycle built for
two was the last word in road scorchers pretty
daring too if you know what i mean of course
sensible folk wrote in buggies we were confident
that nothing could ever replace our buggies
but came a day when some mad dreamer built a
carriage that ran without a horse come here
we all ran out to see this mechanical freak
and when it stopped we yelled get a horse
just a rich man's toy we said well
well what won't they think of next
just a lot of dumb foolishness i call it
first the perpetual motion machine now this
like us not he'll bust his arm cranking the thing
he'll run like blazes almost as fast as a pelican
pedal when it runs it's crazy and it won't work
as i always say a pool needs money we said
it wouldn't run but it did it huffed and
puffed and blew out innumerable tires it
stopped frequently but it started again
and once underway nothing could stop it we jeered
when they quit and laughed when they ran we said
there wouldn't be roads for them but the roads
came it's still a rich man's toy some say not for
long there's a fellow in detroit who'll make them
cheap enough so everybody can own one that's a
good one you and me and everybody riding around in
our own archie mobiles and the marshall standing
out in the street keeping us in line that's funny
well i don't care what you say you'll never catch
me in one of them crazy things driving down the
road scaring chickens not me never that's what
most of us said oh no not me but suddenly
there we were driving the confounded thing
and we learned how to get out
and get under like everybody else
we kept them running with pliers and bent hairpins
and chased squeaks with an oil can and gasoline
alley became the select fraternity of tinkers
there we were happy as larks covered with grease
and lying to our neighbors about miles per gallon
and performance yes we told some whoppers about
what our cars would do and when our neighbors
topped our toll stories we began demanding cars
that would do what we had said our cars would do
we're a strange wonderful people but we're
the boss we made demands and ingenious minds
gave us improvements more cylinders
more performance more miles per gallon
self starting keeping pace with the motor car
designers were the petroleum specialists providing
new fuels new lubricants food and lifeblood for
the new cars and gradually our cars became so
efficient and complicated we couldn't tinker with
them anymore a new institution came into being
and we called it a garage we got our first taste
of free service and we liked it we were saved a
lot of time and bother and we were grateful
at first gasoline alley faded the gas tank
disappeared from our backyards and appeared along
the curb and we called that a filling station
pretty soon we forgot that we had ever patched a
tire or cleaned a spark plug for ourselves after a
while the grease gun disappeared from the tool kit
the filling station took over that job too then
more and more of the irksome jobs we had once
considered fun through the years developed the
especially designed service station prepared
to give more of us more of what we wanted
to treat us the way we like to be treated and the
service driveway became the crossroads of america
that word service meant many things important
things things we the people most of us took
for granted it meant opening new frontiers
battling nature for the flowing gold in the
heart of fever-infested jungles a mile two miles
beneath the ocean floor it meant the development
of amazing refinery processes constantly better
petroleum products at constantly lower prices
it meant the creation of many new types of
petroleum products scientifically suited to
the demands of new cars waterproof grease for
water pumps special lubricants for hypoid axles
overdrive transmissions high-speed engines it
meant new fuels especially designed for all
kinds and ages of motors especially designed even
for variation in climate and seasons all in all it
meant a great scientific march of progress a new
conception of service in personal transportation
yet this service station crossroads was as close
as we the people ever came to the backstage
miracles of automotive progress the man beside
the pump became the ambassador of the skilled army
that worked endlessly behind the scenes to give us
what we wanted were we grateful for his services
you bet we were at first been driving pretty fast
mr summers 10 miles in 32 minutes isn't crawling
i'll say got your windshield all covered
with dust and bugs wait a second i'll
get a rag and clean that off well that's
nice of him yes he's interested in my car
that's why i always stop here but the next time
we came in there yeah mr summers clean as a whole
yeah but how about the back window oh yeah sure
of course dave well the back window gets dirty
too doesn't it our first taste of plus service
gave us an appetite for more more of everything
we were grateful when he put in an air pump
we were grateful when he installed an outside
water line for our convenience and sometimes
we were careful not to leave the water running
then we grew to expect him to fill our radiators
and he better not spill a drop on the hood either
we were grateful every time we were surprised
by a new and unexpected service after that
we took them for granted we thought about
special services only when we didn't get them
once upon a time we never thought of driving
in winter but it wasn't so long before we drove
all winter and fumed if we had to wait a few
hours for the snow drifts to be cleared away
we're annoyed if the car won't start in the
morning we expect the service man through some
magic to anticipate those things we don't
know much about antifreeze we simply drive
into the service station and expect to be fixed
up we just say what am i good for bye below sir
okay okay and we gamble a new radiator perhaps
a new engine that he's right we've learned to
have confidence in him he knows his business he
treats us the boss the way we want to be treated
we accept the service and never
think much about the man behind it
just as we've taken for granted the talents and
techniques which develop the fuel and lubricants
that made possible our new and finer cars every
year we expect new comfort new safety new stamina
new performance new value of course we get them
and we the amazing people accept them as our due
we may marvel at the ingenious tools of modern
progress but do we ever think of the men the
brains and spirit behind all this not very often
facilities are no better than the men behind them
just imagine the modern up-to-date service station
fully equipped but without its expert manpower
here we are full facilities but without the
spirit or leadership of professional service
all right folks help yourselves this station
is on the self-serve cash and gary plan
serve yourselves and let's see how well you do it
wow
so
foreign
it
all right all right let's
put our professional service
back to work but this time let's
not take these men for granted
three blocks straight down
and you'll be on route 32.
good morning say i'll take your car off
your mind hey are we glad to see you
fill her up with red crown and
this time we'll watch what you do
our windshields clean he's checking our water
and oil they're both okay but we like the way
he does it hello what's this he'll give us as
much service as we'll take he's cleaning all of
the glass sweeping the floor that's extra any
good station will give you a cheerful greeting
and clean your windshield and check your gas
and oil but we're getting special service here
thank you won't you come again will we
come again sure we will and right here
we've learned something we can get
the usual service almost anywhere
but when we get the usual services plus
a couple extra we sit up and take notice
let's look over some of the stations that
bring us back again and again and see why
many and varied are the courtesies and extra
services that we find waiting
for us around the next corner
all america rolls past these pumps expecting the
restrooms to be clean the service prompt efficient
and friendly whether we want to fill the tank
change the oil buy new tires or a new battery
or simply get some information all of us we the
funny people have long accepted the remarkable
spirit of service that takes our cars off our
minds we take the service station around the
next corner for granted but no matter how often
we come in the successful dealer never takes us
for granted how smart would we be at sizing up
people how would this man want to be treated
give me five in a hurry that's easy he just wants
quick service what about joker snickety the man
who gasps every time the buttons are near his hood
well the smart service man is extra careful of joe
he holds the hose to keep it away from the car
like this joe worked hard for his car and it's
going to last him a long time professional service
is just as careful of the car as joe himself would
be how about this here's a couple obviously not
in a hurry they'll appreciate all the service
they get they want the works and they'll come
back where they get those extra services the
extra attention they certainly take good care of
us and they're so nice about it i like that smile
this man doesn't expect to buy anything he may
want to use the restroom the telephone or get some
information about the best place to eat but he's a
good potential customer and he'll remember how he
was treated and look an observing serviceman
would begin by offering to check his tires
that one's down a little here's another he's
studying the prices he's a price buyer but he
wants service and extra service will make him
a loyal friend obviously a tourist the service
man who's taken trips himself cracks the ice by
asking how are you enjoying the trip why uh fine
hey this is mighty pretty comfy through here i
was just saying tomorrow as we passed through uh
what was that last time he'll give a mile by mile
description of the trip and it'll make him happy
he's been aching to talk to somebody all day
he's like the traveling man a regular customer
who wants and deserves good service and a friendly
ear for his newest story he may want information
about local business conditions too but take
good care of him and he won't forget you next
time you drive into a service station notice
how quickly these men size you up and give you
what you want in the way you want it plus two
extra services that you hadn't expected at all
it's surprising how courteously and efficiently
these men take our cars off our minds
today the motorcar sets the tempo of life and we
the amazing people won't take no for any answer
at the front doorstep of great cities in
the shadows of the towering skyscrapers
we have cleared space to park our cars during
the business day or shopping adventure if we
can't find parking accommodations in the
business district we tear down a couple
of million dollar office buildings and make
room walk of course not we drive everywhere
we have dinner served on the window ledge of
our cars we even watch the movies from our cars
and after we've taken our exercise watching
a bunch of husky young athletes in action
we go right out to our cars and sit down all the
way home because we drive 400 500 miles a day
we expect sumptuous hotels to bloom in the middle
of the desert we expect good roads all the way to
the fishing grounds and we expect fish too so
the department of conservation stocks the lake
and we have our pictures taken looking
very very proud and maybe a little silly
wherever we are whatever we do today's
civilization is geared to the rolling wheels
and here we go you and i and all of us
amazing funny people taking it all for granted
and looking for greater miracles tomorrow and
they're on the way on the drafting tables and
in the laboratories of automobile designers new
ideas and new ideals are taking form in new cars
of breathtaking beauty and performance
behind barred doors petroleum specialists
are developing new fuels and new lubricants
for faster finer performance at lower cost
on the proving grounds both petroleum
and automotive research is testing the
performance of strange exciting experimental cars
that will step up the tempo of life still further
but how about us we the extraordinary take it
for granted people will we appreciate these
new marvels in imagination let's look ahead 110
look at that only 110 and it's almost wide open
i tell you this crate is underpowered radio
traffic signal slow down to 90 curve ahead
slow down to 90. same old signal same old voice
why don't they put it to music all right wise
guy you asked for it slow down mr i said slow down
mr or you'll break your silly neck so don't blame
no we probably won't change much we'll still
be taking it all for granted and looking ahead
for greater miracles to come but in passing
let's pay a hearty tribute to that army of men
who take our cars off our minds vital to
any community good friends and good citizens
ready to give us all we need and a little more
a salute from we the amazing funny indomitable
people of the united states to the man beside the
pump who is always there round the next corner
the smiling able ambassador of mighty progress
and friendly service in the finest american way